a proposed law in Philadelphia who would
make it illegal for businesses to turn
away customers who only have cash City
Council may vote on a bill to ban
cashless stores next week supporters say
those businesses are unfair to
minorities and the poor David beg no is
at a Philadelphia coffee shop where cash
accounts for about 40% of its sales
David good morning John good morning how
do you pay for your coffee most of the
credit card David Oh mostly credit card
okay well here at La Colombe in
Philadelphia you can use cash in fact if
you look on any money you have right now
it says this note is legal tender for
all debts public and private right so
don't think you hear a lot of people
love to tip and cash when I buy coffee
by the way I usually always use my phone
but here in Philly there are some
businesses that will politely tell you
sorry we're not gonna sell to you if you
only have cash and there's a city
councilman who wants to do something
about it
cash is no longer king as many
businesses in Philadelphia the sounds of
credit card swipes are drowning out the
chicheng of the cash registers there's a
lot of restaurants and other business
that want to go cashless John Longstreet
is the president and CEO of the
Pennsylvania restaurant and Lodging
Association
do you see an upside to cash flows
absolutely because places that handle
cash or less safe than those that don't
have cash on hand
everything is reported directly into the
accounting system taxes are paid whereas
in a cash Society Texas aren't always
paid and consumers are getting used to
it too as well and they're and they're
asking for it cash is not accepted at
bluestone Lane coffee and it's sweet
green the salad chain together they have
six stores in Philadelphia nationwide
dos tauros dig in and tender greens now
refuse paper money reportedly milk bar
Starbucks Amazon Walmart and Shake Shack
have experimented with cashless stores
recently and that trend worries
Philadelphia councilman bill green lady
arguing a cup of coffee I can get it
because I have a credit card but the
person behind me that doesn't have a
credit card is told they can't get a cup
of coffee that something doesn't seem
right about that according to the
federal government more than 14 million
Americans
have bank accounts that makes getting
credit cards difficult a recent survey
by the Pew Research Center found that 34
percent of black people 17% of Hispanics
and 29% of people earning less than
$30,000 rely on cash for all or just
about all of their purchases if it's not
discrimination its elitism I think
government does have a place to protect
people from not being treated fairly
Councilman Greenlee has introduced a
bill that will find businesses in
Philadelphia up to $2,000 if they don't
accept cash similar laws have been
proposed in New York City Chicago in
Washington DC a statewide ban on
cashless stores is awaiting the
governor's signature in New Jersey and
Massachusetts has required retailers to
accept cash since 1978
I might describe it as a solution
looking for a problem do you see the
reasoning behind the thought that
cashless can also be discriminatory
I understand how this has come about
because it would disenfranchise a
certain portion of the population we
should look at it and we should look at
a compromise that allows businesses that
are a are cashless by design in the way
they do business to continue to operate
now if the law is passed it goes into
effect in July and it only affects
brick-and-mortar stores like the coffee
shop here not internet retailers or
membership chains like custo this is
quite the talker let us know what you
think Facebook Twitter Instagram leave
us a comment there beyond what do you
think about this you know I'm torn David
I rely on Apple pay all the time I don't
use cash that much but I see where you
know it would have packed a lot of
people to do so again but to your firm
Nora I'm not sure that you'd want
government to make the decision for you
well and write that business if it if it
stops going Cassius might go out of
business right so that that business
wants to stay in continue collecting
cash sweet cream has made the business
decisions oh we don't need to accept
cash and it might be a liability for us
to continue to accept cash so let the
business there too and I also I agree
with you I think the business should
decide what works best for their
business model by the way this is a
trend and model that banks have forecast
years ago so we're here it's yeah right
I named it thank you enjoy your coffee
yeah
are you on venmo yet no not yet okay
then most way to but I do have a credit
cards yes I've heard of venmo
did you hook up the Apple pay yet sure
I'm gonna give it to Nora yes she's
still very wedded to her abacus spine
Johnson